what are the most beautiful types of
mates or type of mates in my opinion
so top three most beautiful mates would
probably be
on postmates
castling with mates
promote tonight with mates
because those are like the
cool special moves
you can play in chess
okay
one more game
what should i do this game someone tell
me someone give me a fun challenge to
accomplish
someone said try the weirdest opening
ever
when people say ponziani
remote two knights bad opening crab
gambit h pawn
[Music]
f3 potato i could play reverse potato
can't move the same piece twice in a row
that's interesting
it's mother centered mate some of these
are hard to achieve
or queens no castle reverse evans
play alphabetically okay i'll play
alphabetically
wait i'm playing a 2200 what is this
okay but i'm playing alphabetically
alphabetical chess let's see how long i
can keep this up
this is not going to end well
or will it
i should go a b c d
e f g h
i assume knight f6 as long as the
destination square
is f it should count right
alphabetical chess
so far i'm accomplishing this
you six i guess
we have kind of a normal position
and now do i start again from the other
side
or have like accomplished the goal
i feel like i've accomplished the goal
but i'll keep
i'll keep doing it because why not
oh this is so fun
this move actually makes sense
uh
yeah no i'm not gonna follow this any
longer i have to
i have to take the default
what do i take it with the knight
probably the knight
achievement unlocked that was
surprisingly easy i guess because my
opponent didn't take anything so
i was able to do my own thing
thinking about teeing with queen
do i want to play c5 and unleash things
should be for check on the horizon
if we trade queens it's going to be
a bit more positional
thinking g5 soon
thank you phd mini
the prime sub
oh i could play the cabbage
oh the cabbage opening
i forgot about that
because during my potato opening debacle
someone asked if there's another opening
named after a vegetable
and there's a cabbage which i forgot
about
also can i take the bishop
takes king d8
here here
looks really risky
i have rook f8
okay i'll play rook f8
yeah this is gonna get sharp g pawns
hanging
things i need
to my king is also a bit sus
castle
i might as well castle
so the cabbage i might have to play one
more game after this
and try the cabbage
it's like it's kind of like being
or like remembering uh an old toy from
childhood
like so much nostalgia
i'm in trouble here
i feel like i've lost control a little
bit
play this move
pieces are in trouble
this is still really interesting
though position's a little bit uh shaky
for white too
oh i can't take that yet
so i can take here
defending the rook
we this move
captain
hey it's captain stephen gray
oh you're just in time for my really
painful
and tragic death
or my
triumphant
something
wait what's happening here
is it just made in one it's made in one
i thought i was gonna like
tragically perish
but i just made it before white can make
me
that was nice
bishops were too op
oh yeah someone call an ambulance
but not for me
so if you're just joining i played
alphabetical chess
where i started a b c d e f g h
and it kind of worked out
like in this position i don't think
black is much worse
so black is much worse
but then
i was worse for most of this game
plus five but then white blunder
and then i didn't punish it
oh knight c5 would have been a nice move
i was not even on my radar
was that youtube worthy
alphabetical chess
okay if i post this on youtube
then the next video is gonna be the
cabbage opening
and probably in the next game of the
stream
so if you want to see the next video
subscribe to the youtube channel
and stay tuned for the cabbage
also twitch chat says hi
and hehehe backslash